and now we were talking there about
england's coronavirus lockdown although
that will last at least until the start
of december wales so-called fire break
lockdown ends tomorrow
so to talk more about this we're joined
from cardiff by the first minister mark
drakeford thank you very much for being
on the program
so how's your fire break been a success
well we've said all along that we won't
know the effect of the fire break until
beyond the fire break period
but early indications particularly in
things like
travel tell us that people in wales
have done what we've asked to them
they've stayed at home they've worked
from home
they've avoided contact with other
people and when we come out of our fire
break period
tomorrow uh then we will need to go on
doing
everything we can to keep this virus
under proper suppression
it's good to see that you think the
compliance has been pretty good um but
at the same time if you look at the
numbers
weekly infection rates are rising in 14
of the 22 welsh councils
there are now more covered cases per 100
000 people
than when lockdown began it doesn't
sound like it's worked
but that was inevitable sophie wasn't it
the people who have been falling
ill during the two weeks of the fire
break period
were already infectious before the fire
break period
began uh we were absolutely certain that
we would see those numbers continue to
rise
during the fire break period itself it
is only in the couple of weeks
after the 9th of november that we will
see the impact of the fire brick
then is when we hope to see numbers
declining that is when we expect
the number of people going into our
hospitals to begin to go into reverse
i mean i understand with
hospitalizations and sadly of course
with deaths as well
there will be a lag and but i'm talking
about case numbers
is it really responsible to lift
restrictions when cases seem to be going
up
well the advice that we had when we went
into our 17-day fire break period was
but so long as we had a short but sharp
period of restrictions and really people
in wales in these 17 days
we've been back where we were at the end
of march and beginning of april in
terms of restrictions on people's lives
but provided we did everything we could
over those 17 days that would be
sufficient
and as i say it's not a surprise at all
that people who were falling ill
as the fire break began continue to feed
into the system
during the fire break period it's beyond
it we've always said
that we will see the pluses that we have
gained through the actions we have taken
and what if you don't see the outcome
that you're hoping
in the weeks ahead what if cases
continue to rise will you in reintroduce
a lockdown
well we think we have a path through to
christmas where we won't need to take
action
of this sort again it depends though
crucially
not simply on how people behaved during
the fire break period
but on how we all behave in the weeks
that follow it
i've been saying to people in wales that
the question each one of us must ask
ourselves
is not what can i do how far can i
stretch the rules
but what should i do what should i do to
keep myself and other people
safe and if we avoid contact with other
people if we travel only when we
need to if we work from home wherever we
can
we will build on what has been achieved
here over the last 17 days
and that will give us a path through to
christmas without needing
to go back into this extraordinary
period of restriction
now you've also said previously that you
don't want to return to this network of
local restrictions and that was in place
before the fire break but if you look at
some pockets in wales
there's clearly a concern about case
numbers method typical for example
now has the worst infection rate in the
whole of the united kingdom
and yet people living there are coming
out of lockdown should you not
be rethinking this
well what we've said is is that we will
not go back and rely
on a patchwork of local measures we are
going to have a new
national set of rules that are clearer
and i hope simpler
and therefore easier to follow that does
not mean
of course that if there are local
flare-ups that local action may not need
to be taken
uh but it will not be a reliance on
entirely local measures we ended up in
wales with quite a patchwork
of different local restrictions quite
hard for people to follow
a national set simpler clearer and
therefore we hope
easier for people to abide by is the key
way ahead
does that mean that local measures will
not be needed to supplement that in some
cases
no it doesn't and we've never ruled that
out interesting so it could be for
example that people
in murtha if those case numbers continue
to rise could see
local restrictions being imposed
well if there are local restrictions we
will target them at the cause of the
numbers
murtha as you know is the smallest
borough in the whole of wales
relatively low raw numbers drive quite
big
percentage and rate numbers if in murtha
there are specific
reasons we had for example earlier in
the pandemic a factory in mirtha
where there was an outbreak what we will
do instead of taking county-wide
measures
we will try to think of more targeted
things that we can do to bear
down on the cause of any local flare-ups
um interesting stuff um now of course
wales is coming out of lockdown
while england is just starting a
lockdown
and does that need to be restrictions
from people from wales traveling to
the rest of the united kingdom
well people from wales won't be allowed
to travel into england
because of the english lockdown rules
but we don't want to see people
traveling
people who need to travel for work and
medical appointments and so on of course
that's necessary travel but if you don't
have a good reason for traveling
our advice or strong advice to people in
wales is not to do it
the more people mingle and that includes
traveling
the more this virus likes it so our
strong advice to people in wales is
travel where only where you have a
really
necessary reason for doing so and that
certainly includes
at this point traveling across the
border
now you said a bit earlier in the
interview that you were hoping that the
action that you've already taken means
that it won't be necessary to
impose another wales lockdown before
christmas
and boris johnson has said that the four
nations are working on a joint approach
to the christmas period so what could
that look like
well can i just say i think it is really
important that we have a four nation
approach to christmas
so many families in wales have their
friends and other family members
in other parts of the united kingdom and
vice versa
so we were promised last week by michael
gove the minister in charge of the
cabinet office
but we will have another four nation
meeting in this coming week
so that we can pool ideas plan together
have a common approach to the christmas
period i really hope that meeting
materializes because it is only by
getting round the table and
sharing the position each one of us
faces
the challenges we have the common
solutions that we can craft
that we can get to i where i want us to
be and as i say that is a
single approach right across the united
kingdom for
everyone over the christmas period so
does that mean that you're hoping
and that people will be able to go and
see their loved ones their families over
christmas
well christmas is a very special time
for
all of us the restrictions people have
had to live with
are incredibly difficult and demanding
everybody
is tired and fatigued of coronavirus if
we could offer some respite
over the christmas period that is what
we would want to do but it needs to be a
common plan
and a common approach where the rules
are the same as much as we can make them
right across the united kingdom for that
very special period
but as i say the only way to do that is
for us to have that opportunity to meet
and talk together we've been promised
we'll have that opportunity this week
i really hope that the united kingdom
government is serious about this
and make certain that those
opportunities exist for us all
from your conversations with the
westminster government
do you think they are preparing to lift
restrictions over christmas
uh well we haven't had those discussions
yet and the history of coronavirus so
far has been
is that the united kingdom government is
a bit inclined to think about the united
kingdom
when there is a crisis that they
themselves are facing
then we are called often at short notice
around the table again as we were at the
start
of this uh previous week you can't do
that for christmas
you need a forward plan you need a plan
in advance
that's why i am very keen indeed to see
us meet next week
and if we do that then we will be able
to think together
about what is possible we will still be
in the grip of
a public health emergency that will not
have gone away
that is why thinking ahead planning
ahead and having a common plan
is so important okay mark drakeford
thank you very much for coming the
program
and explaining that welsh lockdown thank
you